merci Elisabeth de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure c'est
matrice centriste de la Mayenne
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales on va évidemment
parler de l'examen du texte au Sénat
mais d'abord cette journée de
mobilisation qui s'annonce forte c'est
la sixième elle pourrait être la plus
forte depuis le début du mouvement
est-ce que vous craignez une France à
l'arrêt
il est particulier à notre pays c'est ce
qui a fondé finalement notre projet
social donc pour cette raison on est
tous d'accord et je pense que les
syndicats c'est le rôle simplement les
syndicats doivent avoir ce rôle là en
permanence dans les entreprises dans les
branches bref au quotidien là il se
montre mais j'aimerais qu'en fait il
soit beaucoup plus puissant dans notre
pays qu'il ne le sont au quotidien se
mobiliser pour cette réforme des
retraites sans doute que c'est
nécessaire mais voyez-vous dans dans
beaucoup d'autres pays les syndicats
sont à la manœuvre au quotidien dans
l'entreprise pour discuter pénibilité
pour discuter bien-être au travail et je
pense que 10 défauts pas suffisamment
chez nous je pense que pas suffisamment
chez nous alors la mobilisation
s'annonce importante on a dit est-ce que
l'ampleur de la mobilisation va peser
sur les discussions que vous allez avoir
dans les métiers qu'à partir de cet
après-midi bien sûr que ça pèse c'est
évident après le système paraît ça
pérennité
elle est liée à son équilibre financier
et on ne peut pas passer à côté
de cette évidence que la démographie
aujourd'hui joue elle joue en termes de
de génération c'est à dire qu'en fait on
dans nos familles on a 4 à 5 générations
et on le sait tous et puis il y a le
fait que le taux de natalité est faible
et que dans une même génération et bien
nous avons beaucoup moins d'actifs pour
beaucoup plus de pensionnés et ça c'est
une réalité et je pense que chacun est
capable de le comprendre sauf que la
gauche et les syndicats disent mais il y
a d'autres moyens il y a d'autres moyens
de financer le système par répartition
que de reporter l'âge de départ pour
vous il y en a pas d'autres les autres
moyens c'était augmenter les cotisations
trouver des taxes des impôts on en a
beaucoup débattu cette nuit et puis il y
a le fait aussi de baisser les pensions
et c'est là qu'il faut faire attention
en réalité tous les autres pays d'Europe
sont partis vers une mesure une mesure
de départage beaucoup plus tard arrive
en France nous devons nous y résoudre on
va revenir là-dessus sur les discussions
de cette nuit est-ce que vous nous
confirmez avec certitude désormais que
l'article 7 sera examiné à partir de cet
après-midi c'est probable vers la fin de
l'après-midi on commencera les débats
parce qu'il nous reste l'article 6 et
nous devrions avancer à partir de 14h30
pour oui le début de la fin de
l'après-midi fin d'après-midi et vous
allez si j'ai toute la nuit sans doute
parce que 1300 amendements sur cette
article je pense que ça nous
occupera une partie de la nuit c'est à
dire qu'il pourrait être voté cette nuit
cet article 7 ou le vote pourrait avoir
lieu demain après les questions
d'actualité après je ne sais pas à
quelle vitesse mes collègues
présenteront ses amendements de
suppression et puis comment les choses
se dérouleront dans l'hémicycle mais il
est probable que ça se fasse en début de
matinée peut-être on va sier toute la
nuit et ça le mérite je veux dire que
c'est pas grave qu'on soit fatigué
s'est passé ces jours et ses nuits de
débat les Français ont besoin aussi
d'avoir des explications je pense qu'il
a manqué dans cette affaire d'une vraie
stratégie de communication il y a eu des
maladresses à beaucoup de moments et ça
n'a fait que empirer sur
l'incompréhension des Français vis-à-vis
de cette réforme on va continuer on va
parler évidemment de ce qui s'est passé
ces dernières heures dans l'hémicycle
vous siégé depuis jeudi vous allez
siéger jusqu'à dimanche minuit on va
voir le point sur ces dernières heures
de séance avec Alexandre tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Alex bonjour Oriane bonjour et
Isabelle et à retenir dans ce qui s'est
passé hier notamment le Sénat a voté la
création d'un CDI senior en quoi ça
consiste effectivement rien alors le CDI
senior c'est un contrat qui est censé
inciter les entreprises à embaucher des
salariés de plus de 60 ans avec ce
contrat l'employeur ne paie pas de
cotisation familiale et il peut rompre
le contrat lorsque le salarié atteint à
l'âge de la retraite à taux plein alors
pour la droite sénatoriale et bien ce
contrat va favoriser l'emploi des
seniors alors que le chômage à partir de
60 ans coûte plus de 2 milliards d'euros
à l'assurance chômage chaque année mais
pour la gauche hors de question de voter
cette mesure car les sénateurs de gauche
dénoncent l'efficacité des exonérations
de cotisations sociales pour favoriser
l'emploi et pour la gauche sénatoriale
cela va juste faire plaisir au patronat
on va écouter cet échange entre le
sénateur socialiste Yann chanterelle et
le sénateur les républicains René Paul
Savary initiative de cette mesure
sur le rapporteur Sabari vous aurez dû
renommer votre amendement l'amendement
Medef parce que c'est c'est une commande
directe du Medef cette mesure va dans le
bon sens a déclarer Eric chevet le
vice-président de la CPME on n'est pas
étonné de sa réaction parce que avec ce
CDI senior vous allez permettre au
patron d'être exonéré des cotisations
familles non je ne suis pas servi au
MEDEF à tel point que j'accepte bien
volontiers l'indicateur je crois pas que
ce soit le Medef qui réclame
l'indicateur mais permettez-moi de vous
dire que
j'ai des relations toujours respectueuse
avec les différents partenaires sociaux
voilà l'indicateur c'est l'index senior
en mesure défendue par le gouvernement
pour favoriser l'emploi des seniors
Elisabeth Bono qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à la gauche sénatorielle qui
dit qu'au final le grand gagnant de
cette réforme de retraite c'est le
patronat car aucun effort n'est demandé
dans cette réforme aux entreprises et au
contraire avec cette mesure votée par le
Sénat et bien les entreprises vont même
avoir une baisse de charge
moi je pense qu'il faut arrêter ce
combat entre salariés et patrons ça
c'est d'un autre âge en réalité notre
objectif nous c'est de maintenir et
d'embaucher aussi des seniors dans les
entreprises les seniors ont une
expertise c'est quand même très
malheureux que dans notre pays on ne
garde pas ses compétences et que
finalement
on soit aussi comment dirais-je tiède à
avoir une vraie politique
intergénérationnelle encore là c'est à
dire que les seniors ont des choses à
transmettre aux jeunes on est le pays
désormais où l'apprentissage voilà et
remonter d'une façon vertigineuse et
bien dans ce cas pourquoi ne pas
imaginer du tutorat du mentorat entre
junior et senior on avait ces fameux
contrats de générations qui n'ont pas
fonctionné mais à l'époque
l'apprentissage n'était pas aussi haut
qu'aujourd'hui et là du coup je pense
qu'il faut s'intéresser à un contrat CDI
comment s'est intéressé il y a quelques
temps un CDI pour les jeunes
je crois que toutes les générations sont
utiles dans une entreprise et je
regrette finalement que que la gauche
n'est pas appuyée cette proposition d'un
CDI senior parce qu'elle complète
finalement une boîte à outils pour
maintenir les seniors en activité une
question sur le coup de cette mesure car
il y a une exonération de cotisation
familiale donc ça va coûter à la branche
famille de la sécurité sociale pour
Gabriel Attal le ministre des comptes
publics ça coûterait 800 millions
d'euros par an mais pour les sénateurs
de la républicains ça va même rapporter
de l'argent économiser à l'assurance
chômage au final qui dit vrai c'est vrai
que moi j'ai été surprise par le chiffre
du ministre à 800 millions d'euros parce
que en fait cette c'est moi de recettes
c'est une exonération de la cotisation
famille mais pour autant un seigneur qui
rentre dans un contrat comme celui-ci il
paye toutes les autres cotisations et
son patron paye aussi des cotisations
donc à mon avis d'abord il y aura moins
d'allocations chômage il y aura moins de
dépenses à lunédique parce que ces
seigneurs ne seront pas justement au
chômage et puis d'autre part il y a
aussi toutes les autres cotisations je
rappelle que sur un bulletin de salaire
vous avez plus de 60 % de cotisations
donc si on enlève 5,25 à peu près ce qui
est les cotisations ce que sont les
cotisations familiales patronales il en
reste quand même beaucoup donc je pense
qu'il faut réajuster le coût de ce CDI
on est loin des 800 millions oui moi
j'aimerais avoir un ajustement mais
est-ce que ça va rapporter parce que les
LR ils disent carrément ça va rapporter
de milliards et ça rapporte en termes de
projets de société très franchement le
Seigneur qui reste dans l'entreprise qui
est considéré dans la fin de sa carrière
professionnelle pour moi c'est quelque
chose qui a beaucoup de valeur alors
après on peut se dire effectivement
c'est moindre recettes c'est des
dépenses mais en fait la seule question
qui va c'est qu'on ait une carrière
professionnelle qui aille jusqu'à un âge
avancé qu'on soit pas mis à l'assurance
chômage ou qu'on soit en
en comment dirais-je en carrière
d'incapacité permanente ou autre c'est
un tout en fait sur l'emploi des seniors
il y a une autre mesure c'est l'index
senior que les sénateurs ont voté alors
que les députés l'avaient rejeté
pourquoi l'avoir voté parce que c'est un
outil aussi je pense que ça met en
responsabilité chef d'entreprise qui
nous doit des comptes justement sur
l'intégration des seniors dans
l'entreprise et c'est en fait une
demande de transparence que fait le chef
d'entreprise vis-à-vis de toutes les
générations et en particulier la
génération des seniors donc c'est un
tout et je pense que il faut aussi
regarder aussi les mesures qui seront
proposées par le Sénat un petit peu plus
loin que l'article 7 pour justement
prendre en considération les carrières
qui sont plus pénibles et le départ un
petit peu plus
comment jeûne de l'entreprise quand on
est fatigué on va continuer à voir ce
qui s'est passé hier en séance avec vous
Alex parce que dans le reste de la
discussion il a été question de
fiscalité mais oui des débats qui ont
duré des heures sur ce sujet de la
fiscalité les sénateurs de gauche qui
ont proposé des dizaines et des dizaines
d'amendements pour augmenter les
cotisations retraite sur les entreprises
sur les eaux salaires sur le capital
même les sénateurs centrist s'ils sont
mis avec par exemple certains
silatateurs centrés ce qui ont proposé
une hausse de la CSG sur les revenus du
capital écoutez
nous apparaît pas
outrageant ou trop cuit dans un descend
de solliciter ceux qui ont quelques
moyens puisque il s'agit de plus-value
sur des placements des plus-values sur
le patrimoine immobilier de contribuer à
la solidarité de auquel je pense les
retraités aussi ont droit
et les salariés ont droit
il y a des mesures effectivement des
quitter de justice et on sait très bien
que faire appel à l'impôt pour payer ses
mesures ça nous paraît naturel mais dans
ce débat pour la droite sénatoriale hors
de question d'augmenter les impôts et
pour le gouvernement c'était également
un avis défavorable
défavorable parce que ça nuirait à
l'attractivité de notre pays ça
augmenterait les prélèvements
obligatoires dans notre pays on est
encore deuxième au niveau de l'OCDE
défavorable parce que ça toucherait
aussi des Français qui sont en
difficulté parfois qui tirent des
revenus locatifs et Alex on a dit le
Sénat donc accéléré hier soir et 7000
examens du texte en votant des articles
et aussi de nouveaux amendements oui le
Sénat a voté plusieurs articles comme un
article de la réforme des retraites qui
harmonisent les cotisations patronales
payées en cas de rupture conventionnelle
ou de mise à la retraite d'un salarié on
sera aux alentours de 30% la Haute
Assemblée a aussi voté l'article de la
réforme qui prévoit que la maladie
professionnelle d'un salarié sur la
prise en charge désormais par toutes les
entreprises qu'est-ce qu'il a occupé au
cours de sa carrière et non plus par sa
dernière entreprise et puis les
sénateurs effectivement ont voté de
nouveaux amendements et ils ont modifié
cette réforme ils ont ouvert la voie à
une cotisation retraite minimale pour
tous les travailleurs indépendants alors
que certains travailleurs indépendants
qui sont dans des micro-entreprises
cotisent peu et donc auront de faibles
droits à la retraite et puis pour donner
un nouveau coup de pouce aux pensions de
retraite des femmes et bien les
sénateurs ont voté la création d'un plan
épargne retraite solidaire au sein du
couple alors comment fonctionne ce
nouveau plan épargne retraite et bien
les deux membres du couple l'alimentent
au cours de leur carrière et au moment
de la retraite au moment de liquider ce
plan d'épargne et bien la somme versée à
chacun est inversement proportionnelle à
la somme que chaque membre du couple a
mis dans ce produit d’épargne ça veut
dire concrètement que si le mari a mis
60% et la femme 40% et bien au final la
femme touchera 60% du fruit de cette
épargne et le mari 40% voilà c'est un
mécanisme de solidarité au sein du
couple alors oui effectivement rien le
Sénat considérablement accéléré l'examen
de cette réforme de retraite ils ont
voté dans la nuit l'article 5 ils sont à
l'article 6 et devrait arriver à cet
article 7 qui reporte l'âge de départ à
64 ans en fin d'après-midi c'est ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure et
Elisabeth Denault hier soir Élisabeth
borne sur France 5 elle a dit souhaiter
le moins d'obstruction possible de la
part de la gauche sanatoriale elle fait
de l'obstruction on veut la gauche
sanatoriale non je pense que
l'opposition était dans dans son droit
d'amendement comme tout parlementaire
évidemment on a bien senti que ça allait
assez assez c'était très ralenti par
moment mais c'est normal c'est normal je
pense qu'ils ont aussi apporté des
éléments importants sur des questions
qui sont celles que vous venez de
rappeler notamment sur les
micro-entreprises moi je me suis un peu
intéressé à ce sujet et je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui nous reviendra
comme un boomerang parce que ces
micro-entre en fait et bien c'est
parfois favorisé par aussi un chef
d'entreprise qui va justement mettre au
chômage l'un de ses salariés et lui dire
bien tu crées ta micro-entreprise et
voilà je serai ton principal client mais
il faut pas détourner en fait faut pas
profiter de la loi c'est pour ça que
comme vous l'avez dit on a augmenté la
fiscalité sur la négociation
conventionnelle parce que il ne faut pas
avoir aussi ce réflexe naturel de de
mettre finalement au chômage un salarié
pour profiter justement de cette
négociation conventionnelle et puis
finalement le Seigneur en l'occurrence
finisse sa carrière de façon non
souhaitable parmi les apports du Sénat
l'introduction d'une réflexion sur
l'introduction d'une dose de
capitalisation est-ce que vous brouillez
pas un peu le message des sénateurs qui
justifient leur soutien à la réforme par
le fait qu'il faut sauver le régime par
répartition
alors le but de cette réforme c'est
sauver notre système de retraite par
répartition et donc c'est d'arriver à
l'équilibre financier donc c'est vrai
que c'est le principal objectif il y a
beaucoup de mesures qu'on verra après
l'article 7 pour justement apporter un
peu de solidarité encore plus solidarité
encore plus d'équité dans ce système
pour autant se débat était très
intéressant au Sénat je pense que nous
avons pu
constater les uns les autres que
certains services publics aujourd'hui
qui sont un petit peu défaillants et
bien sont repris par des fonds de
pension étrangers et pourquoi en France
justement la capitalisation collective
ne permettrait pas de financer des
services publics qui ont un petit peu de
mal et en tout cas je pense que chaque
française et chaque français pourrait en
tout cas imaginer que c'est plutôt
quelque chose de positif et d'ailleurs
dans la fonction publique il y a la
Préfon qui permet d'avoir justement la
création de fonds de pension et donc
pourquoi pas dans le sur le plan moi je
pense que il y a pas de tabou à ce sujet
donc dans débattre c'était intéressant
et je rappelle que cet amendement qui a
été voté ce n'est qu'un rapport qui est
demandé c'est un peu l'amendement du
pauvre on va dire mais là l'objectif de
de cette réforme c'est bien de retrouver
l'équilibre pour financer les pensions
des Français alors justement sur un
équilibre Olivier du soft dans Le
Parisien dimanche disait qu'il allait
manquer 300 à 400 millions pour
l'équilibre du régime en 2030 est-ce que
cette réforme vaut vraiment le coup
financièrement bah écoutez ça vaut
vraiment le coup si chacun prend
conscience du besoin financier parce que
j'entends bien il y a beaucoup de
références au rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites mais chacun
observe ou interprète interprète les
courbes à sa façon la réalité c'est que
très très vite
le comment la courbe finalement est
ascendante est très très rapidement
durablement structure également le
système étant danger alors on nous dit
il manquera 13,5 milliards d'euros en
2030 mais il faut aussi penser à
rajouter le cumul de 2029 etc toutes les
années précédentes et donc on arrive à
un système qui est déficitaire de plus
de 90 milliards d'euros il faut pas
oublier qu'on a pas amorti une partie
comment de la dette sur les retraites de
43 milliards environ et c'est énorme et
je pense que la vraie liberté pour les
Français c'est de ne pas avoir cette
dette qui alourdit finalement notre
ambition par rapport à des
investissements et surtout pour protéger
ce modèle social auquel on est attaché
parlons à des maires de famille
elisabethou puisque la mesure qui va
être défendue dans cette réforme des
retraites pour l'améliorer par la
majorité de droite et du centre c'est la
surcote sur les pensions des mers à
partir de 63 ans sur les trimestres
cotisés à partir de 63 ans pour les
maires qui ont une carrière complète
combien va coûter cette mesure
supplémentaire et ce qu'il faut à
compenser cette dépense supplémentaire
par une autre économie
dès le départ le Sénat a pu observer que
il y avait une difficulté pour les
maires de famille pour les femmes en
général d'abord dire que les pensions
des femmes sont quand même entre 25 et
30% plus basse que celle des hommes donc
ça c'était quelque chose qui nous
semblait à corriger d'autre part c'est
ces fameux majorations de durée
d'assurance ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est que lorsque vous n'avez pas
atteint les 43 annuités vous complétez
avec ces trimestres qui ont été accordés
pour une maternité pour une adoption
pour l'éducation d'un enfant mais plus
vous repoussez l'âge de départ à la
retraite et finalement plus vous
compressez ces trimestres qu'il ne vous
servent plus à rien or dans une retraite
par répartition ce qui compte c'est cet
effet intergénérationnel et là il y
avait un défaut qui n'avait pas été en
tout cas pris en compte par le
gouvernement c'est pour ça que le Sénat
a essayé de voir quelle solution
prendre mais vous savez que l'article 40
nous corset en quelque sorte on pouvait
pas proposer une nouvelle dépense et
donc nous sommes comme nous avons
réfléchi nous sommes interrogés et nous
sommes dit la surcotte et sans doute une
des solutions elle est pas satisfaisante
moi je ne suis pas satisfaite parce que
beaucoup de femmes voilà ont travaillé
longtemps ont eu des carrières hachées
ont des temps partiels subis mais
comment corriger finalement toutes ces
imperfections en une seule loi en tout
cas nous dans dans les outils que nous
avions nous n'avions que celui-ci et
donc c'est c'est celui auquel on est
attaché parce que finalement on y a
travaillé on a on a vraiment essayé de
trouver finalement ce qui aurait pu
satisfaire toutes les femmes de ces pays
il était question d'un départ anticipé
Bruno retailleux il proposait aussi un
départ anticipé à 63 ans pour ces femmes
pourquoi du coup ne pas avoir retenu
c'est parce qu'on tombait sur l'article
40 on ne peut pas proposer un amendement
est une dépense qui n'est pas comprise
dans dans le projet actuel les
républicains qui veulent aussi accélérer
la suppression des régimes spéciaux 64
ans en 2040 le groupe centriste est
plutôt contre que dit la rapporteur
général que vous êtes mais moi j'étais
pour effectivement la fermeture de cette
partie des risques vieillesse parce que
tous les autres risques de la sécurité
sociale vont rester dans ces régimes
spéciaux mais il faut dire que ces
régimes spéciaux en fait sont équilibrés
par l'État pour certains ils sont
équilibrés parce que
ils perçoivent des taxes aussi que paye
tous les Français et donc il me semblait
plus juste effectivement qu'aujourd'hui
on aille vers une fermeture alors allez
sur la ligne de chemin moi je suis sur
la ligne du gouvernement parce que donc
la clause du grand-père parce que
aujourd'hui il faut peut-être pas
rajouter de la crispation à la
crispation on le voit bien c'est quand
même un peu compliqué un dernier mot
Elizabeth Doisneau l'a tué est-ce que
vous pensez arriver au bout de l'examen
du texte est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y
aura un vote dimanche ecoutez c'est ce
que souhaite le président du Sénat
Gérard Larcher et je pense qu'on est un
certain nombre à vouloir en tout cas
débattre de chacune des mesures sociales
qui s'ajoutent en fait à cette réforme
des retraites il y a beaucoup de choses
sur la pénibilité et il y a beaucoup de
choses justement sur les carrières
longues même si ces mesures de ces
bornes d'âge en fait ne peuvent être des
comment écrites que par un décret on
veut on veut aussi en parler il y a il y
a beaucoup d'autres mesures sociales qui
sont finalement des mesures de justice
et vous pensez qu'un accord sera trouvé
avec les députés dans la désormais
fameux CMP la commission mixparitaire je
ne me prononcerai pas sur l'Assemblée
nationale non mais sur un accord
sachant que peut-être pas l'ensemble des
députés LR sont plus finalement vous
êtes majoritaire vous avez un doute sur
la le fait qu'elle soit conclusive on
suivra évidemment tout ça ce sera
mercredi prochain merci Alex à tout à
l'heure on continuera à parler des
débats sur la réforme des retraites au
Sénat ce sera dans le club d'abord on va
aller en Mayenne dans votre département
Elisabeth Deano on retrouve Guillaume
bougnold Guillaume merci d'être avec
nous directeur départemental de
westfrance en Mayenne et un sujet en
lien avec la question des retraites
qu'on va aborder avec vous la visite du
ministre des Solidarités Jean-Christophe
combe en Mayenne en fin de semaine
dernière autour de la question des
solutions face aux défis du
vieillissement
[Musique]
la semaine dernière
a pointé un problème lié à la question
du Bien vieillir c'est celle de
l'attractivité de ces métiers du grand
âge alors non seulement ils sont
pénibles ils manquent également de
reconnaissance parfois ce sont des
organisations compliquées pour les
personnes qui
assurent ces tâches
quelque part dans son discours on sent
bien qu'il y a une inquiétude un peu
comparable à celle des déserts médicaux
qu'est-ce que l'on peut faire pour
attirer davantage sur ce métier
bonjour Guillaume c'est vrai que moi
j'ai manqué cette visite du ministre des
Solidarités parce que j'étais déjà dans
l'hémicycles pour parler retraite je
l'ai beaucoup regretté parce que dans
les territoires ruraux comme le
département de la Mayenne c'était
évidemment une préoccupation on voit
bien que ces métiers n'attirent plus
mais il n'attire plus parce que ce sont
des métiers qui sont sans doute pas
assez revalorisés sur le plan du salaire
mais c'est surtout que ce sont là encore
des temps partiels subis et donc il y a
vraiment réfléchir sur qu'est-ce qu'on
met en place pour
réenchanter ces métiers comme dit le
ministre mais aussi pour faire en sorte
que les salariés enfin tous ceux qui qui
sont dans l'accompagnement de la
personne âgée ou handicapée puisse
bénéficier de temps complet c'est
vraiment la question et moi j'ai pu
rencontrer beaucoup beaucoup de ces
personnes qui apportent beaucoup de
temps et et et et d'intention à ces
populations et je trouve que vraiment il
faut écouter et puis trouver ensemble
les solutions est-ce qu'il faut une
grande loi une grande loi sur la
dépendance sur le grand âge sur le Bien
Vieillir ben nous on l'a toujours dit au
Sénat qu'il fallait une grande loi et
vous savez on discute des retraites mais
ça a été promise par Emmanuel Macron
mais tout ça ça a du lien aussi parce
que bien vieillir être bien accompagné
ça fait partie aussi d'un projet
national et on a vraiment regretté même
si le gouvernement a mis en place cette
branche autonomie qui est une bonne
chose on voit bien qu'il manque
finalement une histoire une histoire et
c'est pas tout n'est pas lié je vois par
exemple il y a deux ans au cours du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale l'a été proposée des
EHPAD ressources mais finalement les
territoires ne se sont pas encore
emparés de cette proposition
c'est-à-dire comment on intègre
finalement mutualistes du personnel pour
justement offrir des temps complet à des
personnes qui vont au domicile mais qui
compléteront leur temps dans un EHPAD
merci Elisabeth Doisneau merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin on vous
souhaite bon courage pour cette journée
qui s'annonce longue et cette nuit qui
s'annonce longue et évidemment de
l'examen de cet article 7 il sera à
suivre en direct sur Public Sénat
jusqu'au bout de la nuit on suivra ça
avec vous je montais une de Guillaume la
Une de westfrance réforme des retraites
une journée décisive c'est à la Une de
westfrance merci Elisabeth Lanau on va
continuer évidemment notre édition
spéciale réforme des retraites on verra
comment se prépare la journée de
mobilisation dans nos régions on sera à
Rennes à Marseille à Annonay en Ardèche
la ville d'Olivier du SO